you might remember or you might not
because corporate media basically hasn't
covered this which is that donald trump
has been accused not just of sexually
assaulting more than a dozen adult women
but of raping a 13 year old girl and
i've told you before
that this event allegedly took place
along with one of donald trump's i don't
know if we call him an associate or an
acquaintance or a friend but
it's a guy named jeffrey epstein a woman
known
only as jane doe previously had alleged
that when she was 13 years old
donald trump raped her at a party thrown
by jeffrey epstein
and that epstein himself had also
raped her now the woman ended up fearing
for her life
and dropping a civil suit against donald
trump
but of course the allegations themselves
have not been
recanted epstein has been sort of a
slippery guy to actually
charge uh of with some of these um
incidents but he has now been arrested
and charged with sex
trafficking dating back to the early
2000s he is now
facing charges for paying underage girls
for massages
and molesting them in florida and new
york
homes that he owns and before we even
get to the trump connection
because that's a whole other thing i
have to tell you
that the right is spreading endless lies
already about epstein one example is
the right is saying the robert mueller
fbi
allowed epstein to plead to lesser
charges
and avoid a long jail sentence the truth
is
that the deal epstein previously got for
charges
was from the then miami u.s attorney
alexander acosta
who happens to be trump's labor
secretary now
this is now really bad the records say
epstein brought
40 girls who were underage to his
florida mansion
and they were sold into sexual
encounters of all kinds
these allegations are truly disgusting
and disturbing and then the trump piece
pops up trump said about jeffrey epstein
to new york magazine in 2002
quote i've known jeff for 15 years
terrific guy
he's a lot of fun to be with it is even
said that he likes beautiful women as
much as i do
and many of them are on the younger side
not good not good so back to the
allegations that donald trump
raped one of the same girls that epstein
allegedly raped when
she was 13 at epstein's manhattan condo
i don't know if they're going to
resurface here as a result of this
arrest but this is certainly not what
donald trump would consider to be
good news to have jeffrey epstein back
in the public spotlight
in this way now i've looked at the
content of the lawsuit that again was
filed against donald trump for the rape
the charges were eventually dropped
supposedly
because of death threats against the
accuser it is shocking
what is in the the lawsuit i'm not going
to read it to you it's dozens of pages
but you can easily find it online and
we're going to link to it on youtube
the accuser claimed before the lawsuit
was was withdrawn
just as a few highlights that trump
threatened her
to never talk about the rape or she
risked being
hurt or killed which is exactly in line
with the intimidatory tactics that we
know donald trump has employed
against such former mistresses as stormy
daniels
so it's all truly sick i mean it really
makes me sick
and much like with much of what's going
on with donald trump
there may never be consequences but with
epstein back in the news
we will see and consider the number of
conflicts
that are involved here donald trump is
or was friends with jeffrey epstein the
old prosecutor from miami
is now trump's labor secretary attorney
general william barr
has recused himself from the entire
jeffrey epstein case
because his former law firm once
represented
epstein this is another reminder of the
incestuous
nature of power influence and wealth in
this country
and donald trump knows that this is not
good for him
and he actually is on tilt next i want
to talk about what he did
at a rally to someone who held up a
picture of him with jeffrey epstein
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
skillshare
when you click the link underneath this
video skillshare
is a vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25 000 video classes
on just about
anything you can think of get better at
playing an instrument
learn to use photoshop how to edit
videos
they have classes on drawing painting
business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and i'm not even
really scratching the surface i recently
took a great class on
introductory watercolor painting
i'm still not good but i am learning and
you can access
the entire library of fun easy to use
online courses for free for two months
by using the link underneath this video
two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
i've gotten a ton out of it
pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable
and i think you'll love it too get
started for free by clicking the link
under this video